Exactamente 484 días después de
comenzar la invasión de Ucrania,
el régimen de Vladimir Putin se enfrentó
a un intento de golpe de Estado que
ha dejado al descubierto las grandes
debilidades de un país que hace aguas.
A finales de febrero de 2022 Vladimir Putin
estuvo a punto de hacerse con Kiev. Ahora ha
estado en riesgo su control sobre
Moscú y quizás sobre toda Rusia.
La pregunta que ahora todos nos hacemos es:
Exactamente, ¿qué demonios ha pasado? ¿Por qué ha
pasado? Y probablemente la pregunta más importante
de todas: ¿Qué podemos esperar a partir de ahora ?
Pues bien, os lo vamos a contar todo
en este vídeo. Prestad mucha atención
porque habrá cosas que ya sepáis pero otras
que, seguro, seguro, os van a sorprender.
Arranquemos.
Sábado 24 de junio de 2023, armadas, pertrechadas
y listas para el combate, las tropas de un señor
de la guerra atraviesan a toda velocidad
el territorio ruso para hacerse con Moscú.
El Kremlin mientras tanto, acorralado y atónito
intenta frenar el avance de esta columna armada
poniendo barricadas, cortando carreteras
y saboteando puentes. Todo es inútil,
las tropas del señor de la
guerra avanzan sin descanso.
Queridos amigos, amigas, en esta ocasión
no se trata de ninguna película de
Hollywood, no estamos ante un texto escrito por
un guionista motivado ni nada por el estilo. En
esta ocasión esta historia es completamente
cierta. Todos hemos sido testigos de ella.
Los días 23 y 24 de junio de 2023
lo impensable se hizo realidad.
Yevgeny Prigozhin, el líder del
grupo de mercenarios Wagner le
echó a Vladimir Putin el mayor pulso que se
recuerda en la historia de la Rusia moderna.
Ahora bien, en este vídeo no os vamos a
contar quién es exactamente Prigozhin,
cómo funciona el grupo Wagner o cómo es
posible que llegara a tener 50.000 soldados
y se hiciera con la única gran victoria de Rusia
en Ucrania desde el mes de abril de 2022: Bakhmut.
No lo haremos porque de todo eso ya os hemos
hablado en varios vídeos que
os dejamos en la descripción.
Por eso, en esta ocasión vamos a centrarnos
en esta singular historia más propia de una
superproducción de Hollywood que
de los noticiarios de actualidad.
Y lo primero de todo es saber qué
pasó y cómo se llegó hasta aquí.
Pues, veréis, los altos mandos del ejército
ruso y el líder del grupo Wagner llevan meses
tirándose los trastos a la cabeza. Y no penséis
que lo hacen precisamente en privado. Prigozhin
ha hecho entrevistas, vídeos y publicaciones en
redes sociales para denunciar la incompetencia y
la corrupción de los gerifaltes militares
de Rusia, particularmente del Ministro
de Defensa Serguéi Shoigu y del Jefe del
Estado Mayor, el general Valery Gerasimov.
(Por su parte, tras la captura de Bakhmut,
el Ministerio de Defensa puso en marcha un
plan para reducir el creciente peso del grupo
Wagner, para ello enrolaría en el ejército a
los reclutas de este grupo y pondría toda
su estructura bajo el control del ministro
Shoigu. Algo que por supuesto era completamente
inaceptable para el mandamás de Wagner. Al fin
y al cabo eso hubiera supuesto en la práctica
su disolución. ¿Su respuesta? Incrementar sus
denuncias por corrupción e incompetencia
masiva contra los altos mandos militares.
Y así, de esta forma la tensión entre ambas partes
fue escalando como la temperatura
de un volcán a punto de erupción.)
Con todo, el pulso definitivo se puso
en marcha el viernes 23 de junio,
cuando Prigozhin acusó al ejército
ruso de atacar los campamentos de
su grupo de mercenarios, matando a
un montón de combatientes de Wagner.
Culpó específicamente al ministro de defensa
ruso Sergey Shoigu y prometió tomar represalias.
Y vaya si lo hizo. En un vídeo
de 30 minutos… el líder de los
Wagner se deshagó a gusto. Dijo de todo:
Reconoció que la guerra de
Ucrania no estaba justificada.
Dijo que las élites del gobierno
ruso eran una panda de corruptos.
Y dijo que todo se había orquestado para llenar
los bolsillos de los jefecillos de turno.
Claro que eso sería solo el comienzo
El siguiente paso fue ocupar la ciudad de
Rostov, una importante ciudad de más de 1
millón de habitantes y un centro militar
absolutamente clave para el esfuerzo de
guerra de Rusia en Ucrania. Desde luego
esto supuso cruzar una línea de no retorno.
Y, amigos, mientras los Wagner se preparaban
para ocupar Rostov, el sábado 24 de madrugada,
el fiscal general de Rusia anunció que se
estaba investigando a Pregozhin por orquestar
precisamente una rebelión.
Y aún más, unas horas después el propio Vladimir
Putin se dirigió a la nación y acusó a su antiguo
aliado de ser un traidor. Prometió castigar a los
responsables con toda la dureza posible. Fijaos.
Claro que el punto álgido de esta
especie de pulso aún estaba por
llegar. Poco después las tropas del
grupo Wagner confirmaron lo que ya
habían anunciado: ni más ni menos que ponían rumbo
a Moscú. Lo llamaron “marcha por la justicia”
Y, ojo que no se trataba de ninguna
broma. Aunque en la operación de Wagner
no se llegó a ver ningún gran despliegue
de tropas y equipos, el Kremlin tuvo que
poner en marcha los planes que había de la era
soviética para defender la capital. De locos.
(En previsión de la llegada de las tropas
de Pregozhin se colocaron barricadas,
se bloquearon carreteras, se
sabotearon algunos puentes
y se desplegó a todos los efectivos
disponibles. Conforme a los planes,
Moscú quedaría bajo la custodia de la 4ª División
de Tanques de la Guardia "Kantemirovskaya" y la 2ª
División Motora de la Guardia. Se calcula
que unos 6.000 hombres en total. Junto a
ellos unidades de las fuerzas especiales de
Spetsnaz; la Guardia Nacional y la policía.)
Finalmente nada de esto fue necesario. Como todos
sabéis a última hora de la tarde y cuando el grupo
de mercenarios se encontraba ya muy cerca de
la capital se anunció una especie de tregua.
Los Wagner dieron marcha atrás después
de haber cruzado cientos de kilómetros
sin oposición alguna y después de haber
derribado 6 helicópteros y un avión del
ejército ruso. Pese a ello, Rusia ha retirado
de la mesa cualquier acusación por rebelión.
Pero como os digo, queridos amigos
todo esto es algo que estoy seguro,
absolutamente seguro de que todos ya sabéis.
Sin embargo, hay unas cuantas
preguntas que tenemos que hacernos:
¿Por qué Prigozhin se lanzó a semejante
aventura? ¿Qué ha significado realmente
esta incursión golpista? ¿Por qué
se frenó la tentativa de golpe de
Estado de los Wagner cuando estaban
tan cerca de Moscú? Y seguramente la
pregunta más importante de todas: ¿Qué puede
suponer todo esto para el futuro de Rusia?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1(CRÓNICA DE UN DESMADRE ANUNCIADO)
Os lo hemos contado en VisualPolitik en
un montón de vídeos: más allá de toda la
propaganda que existe, lo cierto es que la
guerra de Ucrania está siendo un desastre
colosal para Rusia. Prácticamente ningún ruso
está ganando nada y la mayoría están perdiendo.
En el país la economía se está resintiendo y las
proyecciones futuras son muy pobres. Ahora los
rusos están mucho más aislados y la libertad
de expresión se ha reducido aún más si cabe.
Por su parte, los grandes oligarcas
han perdido una fortuna y muchísima
libertad. Digamos que su lujoso
tren de vida viajando y siendo
agasajados por todo el mundo se
ha visto seriamente comprometido.
Pero por supuesto la peor parte
se ha producido en Ucrania. Desde
que dio comienzo la guerra las bajas han
sido salvajes, Rusia ha perdido una gran
parte de su fuerza militar y ahora,
para colmo, están a la defensiva.
El contraataque ucraniano puede que
esté siendo más lento de lo esperado,
pero está castigando durísimamente a
las ya de por sí exhaustas tropas rusas.
Y, ojo, esto no lo decimos nosotros. Lo
dice el propio Prigozhin, un tipo que
durante meses ha sido la cara visible
del esfuerzo militar de Rusia. Fijaos.
Pero no se trata solo de Prigozhin. Lo cierto es
que los datos que se van conociendo
no invitan al optimismo… Para Rusia.
Por ejemplo, los datos de las
fuerz as armadas ucranianas,
reconocidos en buena medida por el propio
Prigozhin, apuntan a que las bajas de Rusia
están siendo no solo muy superiores
a las de Ucrania, sino dos veces más
altas que las sufridas cuando comenzó la
ofensiva de Kherson en el verano de 2022.
Y lo mismo podemos decir de las pérdidas de
equipo. Y sí, ya sé lo que estáis pensado.
Pero vamos a ver, Alberto… ¿Datos de
Ucrania? ¿Estás de broma? Esos están
más maquillados que las hamburguesas
que salen en los anuncios de la tele.
Pues sí, es muy probable que sea así, pero
también lo es que de estar maquillados ahora
también lo estaban en el verano del 2022. Y
que los datos occidentales van en la misma
línea y que el propio Prigozhin también
lo está reconociendo. Y por eso lo que
nos importa no es el dato en concreto sino
la tendencia que está siguiendo la guerra.
Os hablaremos de esto con todo lujo de detalles
en un próximo vídeo aquí en VisualPolitik.
Lo que aquí nos importa ahora
es que esto no es algo nuevo.
Durante meses el líder del grupo
Wagner ha denunciado a los altos
gerifaltes rusos por no proporcionarles
la munición y el equipo necesarios. Y
les ha culpado de las grandes pérdidas sufridas.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Esto resulta algo fundamental.
El fracaso militar en Ucrania está obligando
por un lado a buscar culpables. Y por
otro está creando grietas en el sistema
que muchos pueden querer aprovechar
para incrementar su poder. Que es,
precisamente, lo que parece haber hecho
Prigozhin durante los últimos meses.
Por un lado lavar su responsabilidad
y señalar a otros como culpables antes
de que esos otros le señalaran a él. Por otro
lado, subir peldaños en el escalafón de poder.
Y por eso el propio líder de los Wagner ha
exigido por activa y por pasiva la destitución
de los grandes gerifaltes del gobierno ruso y
constantemente les ha llamado de todo. Y como
evidentemente Shoigu, Gerasimov no se han quedado
de brazos cruzados pues… Hemos llegado hasta aquí.
Pero, un momento, porque toda esta historia
nos deja unos cuantos interrogantes:
¿Por qué el ejército, incluida la fuerza aérea,
no actuó ni tampoco se movilizó claramente para
repeler el golpe? ¿Es que acaso en el Kremlin
no se fiaban de que alguna división pudiera
incumplir sus órdenes y ponerse de lado de los
sublevados si se elevaba aún más la tensión?
¿Por qué el propio Putin acusó por la mañana
a los Wagner de ser unos traidores y dijo
que recibirían su castigo para luego
horas más tarde dejarlos marchar de
rositas? ¿Es que en el Kremlin no tienen
claro que puedan vencerlos fácilmente?
¿Por qué recurrir a un intermediario
como Lukashenko? ¿Es que acaso
tuvieron miedo de que se pudiera llegar a perder
Moscú, o al menos una parte de la capital con
el golpe político que eso hubiera supuesto?
¿Por qué Putin y el resto de altos
cargos del gobierno estuvieron tan
desaparecidos? ¿Realmente el presidente abandonó
Moscú por miedo a lo que pudiera pasar?
¿Ya no se fía de su círculo más próximo?
¿Cómo es posible que tal y como se ha
confirmado la inteligencia americana
supiera desde hace días las intenciones de Wagner
y al Kremlin en cambio pareció pillarle todo por
sorpresa sin ningún preparativo efectivo?
¿Es que acaso la información ya no fluye?
¿Por qué Prigozhin se lanzó contra Moscú y cuando
estaba tan cerca se dio la vuelta aparentemente
sin ningún éxito concreto? ¿Es que acaso esperaba
el apoyo de alguna facción crítica con el gobierno
que finalmente no se materializó? ¿Fue este
el caso del comandante de las Fuerzas Aéreas,
el general Surovikin, y del subjefe
del GRU, el teniente general Alekseyev,
que hicieron sendas declaraciones algo extrañas
llamando a los Wagners a desistir? ¿Estaban acaso
detenidos o estaban siendo forzados
cuando hicieron estas declaraciones?
¿Puede ser que el líder de Wagner haya
palpado una creciente distancia entre
las filas militares y el gobierno, y
de esta forma pensara que su acción
podría desencadenar un efecto dominó…
pero que al final eso no se produjo?
No lo sabemos, pero esta es la teoría a la
que apuntan los servicios de inteligencia
occidentales, podría explicar por
qué se dio la vuelta y, también,
por qué Putin no quiso movilizar a las fuerzas
armadas ni enfrentarse directamente a los Wagner.
En cualquier caso, ya veis que toda
esta historia nos deja muchas preguntas,
para las cuales por ahora no
tenemos más que conjeturas.
Pero amigos, amigas, mejor o peor
montado e independientemente del
riesgo que supusiera realmente,
lo cierto es que el golpe de mano de Prigozhin
ha dejado una cosa muy, pero que muy clara.
C5(La mafia es como la mafia. Sea cual
sea el acuerdo al que se llegó hoy,
se ha derramado sangre y la ilusión de
invencibilidad de Putin se ha desvanecido.
Él y sus compinches probaron el miedo real.
Moscú estaba amenazado. Garry Kasparov)
Amigos, amigas, el poder de
Putin ya no es el de antaño.
Atentos.
T2(¿EL JEFE EN ENTREDICHO?)
Durante la guerra de Ucrania el
grupo Wagner y especialmente su
líder han cobrado cada vez más y más protagonismo.
Primero como líder de las principales
operaciones, después como azote de la
cúpula militar y últimamente también como
protector de los pobres soldados rusos.
(Para ello no ha dudado en grabar vídeos
condenando la pérdida de soldados rusos,
ha hecho regalos a sus viudas y a
sus madres y sobre todo ha dicho
verdades sobre la guerra que nadie
más se atrevía a decir en Rusia.
Estas son cosas que en Rusia venden y mucho… Lo
que ha multiplicado su popularidad. Solo hay que
ver cómo abandonó Rostov entre aplausos y vítores,
tras acordarse la tregua con el gobierno.)
Pero, ¿por qué Putin permitió durante tanto tiempo
que este tipo atacara sin cuartel
a su gobierno, os preguntaréis?
Pues bien, una de las razones que se barajaban
es que con todas estas denuncias
ayudaba al propio presidente ruso.
Es decir, me explico, su buen amigo y aliado
ponía en la diana a personajes como Shoigu o
Gerasimov. Ellos eran los auténticos culpables
de lo mal que iban las cosas, no el Presidente.
Sin embargo, con su vídeo del viernes 23
de junio todo cambió. Porque una cosa es
decir que falta munición y otra muy
distinta decir abiertamente que los
argumentos para justificar la
invasión fueron una patraña.
Y por eso Putin salió en televisión a
decir que Prigozhin era un traidor. ¿El
problema? Que de facto se ha tenido que retractar.
Aparentemente ya no le va a perseguir. Y eso es un
problema… Porque deja claro que el mandamás
de Rusia ya no tiene tanto poder como antes.
C6(Me veo obligado a admitir con
amargura que la Federación de Rusia
se ha acercado un paso más a su
muerte definitiva e irrevocable.
C7("Hoy, el mundo vio que los
amos de Rusia no tienen control
sobre nada. Solo un completo caos. Zelensky)
Sí, es verdad que aparentemente según el acuerdo
alcanzado Prigozhin parece que dejará Rusia… Pero,
¿Significará esto que dejará su creciente
influencia? ¿Renunciará a manejar los hilos?
Ya veis que hay serias dudas. También está por
ver qué ocurrirá con la cúpula militar. Si Putin
hace cambios eso podría interpretarse
como parte del acuerdo con Wagner.
Pero sea como sea, si algo está claro es que todo
esto ha supuesto un enorme varapalo para Putin.
El presidente ruso ha provocado un desastre en
Ucrania, está perdiendo la guerra y ahora esto.
Fijaos en lo que decía en el mes de
enero el periodista ruso Mikhail Zygar:
C8(“El presidente Vladimir Putin de Rusia, al
parecer, finalmente se ha dado cuenta de que
la guerra en Ucrania creó un peligroso competidor
para su poder: Yevgeny Prigozhin. Mikhail Zyga )
Por supuesto lo del motín fue ir mucho más allá.
Putin ya no da el miedo de antaño y eso, eso es
lo peor que le puede pasar a un autócrata. En
regímenes como este el poder del presidente
se basa esencialmente en su capacidad para
atemorizar, infundir respeto y castigar cualquier
disidencia. Pero en esta ocasión hemos visto cómo
una organización de 25.000 mercenarios se
apoderó del centro neurálgico de operaciones
para la Guerra de Ucrania y avanzó hacía
Moscú sin que pasara absolutamente nada.
El hecho de que esto haya sido moderado
por Lukashenka me parece extremadamente
vergonzoso. ¿Putin necesita que alguien
más resuelva sus problemas? Sam Greene,
experto en Politca rusa, Director de CEPA
y profesor del King’s College de Londres)
Y no olvidéis que en marzo de
2024 se celebrarán elecciones.
Que sí, lo sabemos. En Rusia las elecciones están
más amañadas que la elección del mundial de Qatar.
Pero aún así.. Veremos si Putin consigue
llegar y si logra presentarse a la reelección.
Pensadlo bien, la gran propuesta, el gran
compromiso del presidente ruso siempre ha
sido rescatar a Rusia de la anarquía y restablecer
su grandeza. Pero ahora todo se ha hecho añicos.
Rusia no es más fuerte, su ejército va de
mal en peor, no hay prosperidad en el país,
los grandes oligarcas están perdiendo
y para colmo el caos es tan grande
que un señor de la guerra puede
pasearse tranquilamente por el
país amenazando con ocupar la capital
sin que le pase absolutamente nada.
Por si fuera poco el acuerdo alcanzado
con los Wagner parece conllevar la salida
de este grupo armado de una Guerra
que todavía no ha terminado… Y os
recuerdo que hasta ahora este grupo ha sido clave.
C10(“Wagner fue el único elemento exitoso
de la invasión rusa durante un año. Y su
éxito fue muy limitado y se centró en
una pequeña ciudad y sus tácticas fueron
bárbaras incluso para el personal de Wagner.
Pero al menos lograron algo. El ejército
ruso no podía”. Andriy Zagorodnyuk,
exministro de defensa de Ucrania)
La pinta que nos deja todo esto es la de un país
en descomposición. Y, ojo, que hay precedentes.
En 1991 el líder soviético Mijail Giorvachov
logró sobrevivir a un golpe de estado. Pese
a ello solo cuatro meses después ya estaba fuera
del gobierno. El golpe mostró su enorme debilidad.
¿Estaremos ahora ante una situación
muy parecida? Os hablaremos de todo
ello en un próximo vídeo aquí en VisualPolitik.
De momento, el turno es para ti:
¿qué opinas del golpe de mano de
los Wagner? ¿Quién crees que ha perdido
más, Prigozhin o Putin? ¿Crees que el líder
ruso conseguirá recuperarse de todos estos
varapalos? ¿Cómo afectará esto a la guerra
de Ucrania? Déjanos tus impresiones
en los comentarios y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a VisualPolitik si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima